[Music]
personal achievement sponsored by Stover
school ian leslie ian is represented
Sheldon Bowling Club for 20 years
joining the team when he was just 10
years old ian has enjoyed great success
locally regionally and nationally and he
also represents Devon in England a
long-standing member of his local club
last season Ian played his part in
helping win the Mid Devon League and the
county team trophy and in July ian was
honored to be selected to join the
England squad in the recent home
international series at Royal lemmings
in Spa bowling against Wales Ireland and
Scotland and finishing in a very close
second place the same month ian was also
selected as one of four men to play
against Australia in a one-off Test
match Mollie Mayhew Molly has congenital
proximal radioulnar synostosis which can
prove physically challenging for her
this does not stop her from trying her
best
she gives every dance lesson and every
BMX session 110 percent resulting in her
achieving a silver medal in BMX and a
gold medal in dance events at the Youth
Games after having anxiety issues during
competing in the Youth Games Molly
overcame fears of taking on some of the
larger features of the skate park to get
awarded a silver medal with their
teammates this is given Molly so much
confidence and encouraged her to thrive
not just at bmxing but with her dancing
to Molly's efforts at the Youth Games
help team bridge get overall 1st place
at Doris in July
[Music]